[Applaudissements]
allez on va passer à ce test dont je
vous ai parlé alors si on regarde on va
voir la photo 1 c'est un truc qui fait
un carton en chine en ce moment ça fait
le tour des réseaux sociaux ça s'appelle
le finger chap
alors vous avez tous essayé faire le
décès de faire le test il faut poser son
index sur le nez regardez comme la seule
firme son index sur le nez en essayant
de le connecter au menton si les lèvres
autres en contact avec le doigt c'est
con époux sinon sinon je vous le dis
sachez lost une mauvaise nouvelle vous
n'êtes pas écrase le nez lui la colle
pour tout le monde la malaria là pour
qui ça colle pas vous perdez vous
regardez sa cote pas comment ça va
démarrer
on va les voir les par intérim au centre
icher thierry moreau déjà thierry moreau
sa touche ou pas ça marche
donc vous êtes beau jean michel mr
latouche fils jean michel c'est pas nous
c'est la crainte il écrase sourit il est
grand il faut pas écraser isabelle
morini-bosc sa touche pas ma psy
[Applaudissements]
ah oui ça touche à ces messieurs
je recommande mettez vos profils très
fleur bleue que moi ça touche à touche
touche pas tellement arrêtés en chine
vous est dégueulasse tous les asiatiques
ont des petits dés ce normal que ça
touche mais non mais regardez moi ça
touche
enora et oui ça touche pas sa touche sa
touche générant sera touche à ta
connerie et touche
je sens que je suis d'accord avec elle
j'ai gardé ça nous touche pas si j'ai un
gros nez s'allonge quand même c'est que
twitter est beau mais là ça commence à
tous pas ça tous pas prise et non comme
ça il tomber le barça nous sommes tous
pareils et c'est comme ça christophe
carrière on sait que vous êtes bon chine
voilà à les voler et merci
bah ça ça cartonne sur internet
comme quoi ils peuvent nous faire faire
n'importe et austin une bague est en jeu